♪♪
This is Jamestwon actual.
Enjoy the show everyone.
♪♪
Yeah baby.
Welcome
-Welcome
to the For All Mankind
Season 2
time capsule.
♪♪
Time to strap in.
Alright...
♪♪
Welcome to the 1980's.
Karen now owns the Outpost.
The famous astronaut
watering hole
and Kelly the
daughter she and Ed
have adopted works
there with her.
But when Kelly tells
Ed and Karen
that she wants
to join the Navy,
Ed is furious.
Terrified at the thought
of losing another child.
The answer's no!
Dad, I get to have —
End of story!
I remember when you told me
that you wanted to join
the Naval Academy.
And now it turns
out our daughter
wants to be in the Navy, too.
We are the Baldwins.
In addition,
tech and lunar exploration
have taken huge strides.
Margo is now head of NASA
and Ellen is wrapping up
her time on Jamestown.
A massive solar storm
threatens everyone,
and Molly....
gets the worst of it.
Exposed to radiation,
Molly starts losing
her vision and is
reluctantly forced
to return home.
Back on earth,
Ed is now a putter
swinging desk jockey.
All that practice in your office
has really been paying off.
Dani’s yearning to
get back into space.
I'm trying to get
back to my old self.
And Gordo...
Well...
You’ll see.
Don’t even get me
started on the food,
might as well have
been eating cardboard.
(crowd laughs)
Ed helps them both.
By getting Dani and Gordo
back into space training.
Which appears to be
a little easier for Dani.
While Gordo was expanding...
His now ex-wife
Tracy is a hero and
has become something
of a celebrity.
Traveling back to a now much
larger Jamestown base.
Meanwhile Cold War tensions
explode when the Soviets
shoot down a passenger
plane with Americans on board.
And commandeer our
lunar dig sight.
Got situation over here.
So these events force the
Marines we have on the moon
to take back the site
and protect the base.
God bless you and
God bless America.
As things heat up in space,
Gordo gets in shape,
determined to get back to
Jamestown to win
back his ex-wife Tracy.
She's actually my wife now.
For the moment.
And Ed finally gets out
from behind the desk
to prepare for his mission
aboard the Pathfinder.
Meanwhile, NASA and the Soviets
create an uneasy alliance to
prove there is peace
between the two,
working together to make
a connection in space.
But some of us...
To our shared secrets.
-Make more of a
connection than others.
And speaking of
more than an alliance.
Ellen manages a reconnection
of her own, with Pam.
Would it be weird for us
to get a drink sometime?
I mean it would be...
Nice.
And Karen, well, she finds
comfort in the Outpost
basement with Danny Stevens.
Come on!
What?
(squeals)
I can't, I just can't.
Yes, she, does.
Get it Karen!
Yes!
(clears throat)
Seriously? Gordo's son?
Anyway, while, sparks
fly on Earth,
gunshots are raining
down on Jamestown.
A stray bullet hits the cooling
pump of Jamestown's
nuclear reactor.
And it's only a matter of
time before it explodes,
killing everyone on the Moon.
And it's my character
Aleida Rosales.
Yep! That's young me with Margo,
except that doesn't go so well.
Maybe I could stay with you...
I'm sorry, I shouldn't
have asked.
Which lead to...
I can offer you a job at NASA.
Ah. Poor little Mexican girl,
you know, she got
a big job at NASA
'cause Margo Madison
took pity on her.
I didn't come here out of pity.
Guilt's a close cousin.
Yeah, not great.
But, it gets...
Better.
Yes!
What I'm really
trying to get to,
is she's the one who notices
the message from Gordo
that Jamestown is under attack.
Hello?
Hi.
And this leads to a powerful,
pivotal moment, for
Gordo and Tracy.
The nuclear reactor's control
computer has gone offline.
What can we do?
Together again, they
make their final stand...
And save Jamestown.
(intense music playing)
You.
Will. Be.
Missed.
At the same time,
Dani goes rogue,
and disobeys direct orders
to abort her mission.
She docks with the Soyuz...
And peace is restored.
(crowd cheering)
The handshake in space has
become a handshake
to save the world.
President Reagan was so moved
by the images that
it inspired him
to reach out his
own hand in peace.
Our final shot of season 2
gives us a tease of what's
to come in season 3.
Hint. Hint.
This leaves one key question:
Whose boots are they?
I guess you'll have to find out.